[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar the changing landscape of sexual
health and stis in the u.s
i am marie stone of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by roche diagnostics to learn more
visit diagnostics.roche.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
patricia j kissinger professor tulane
university school of public health and
tropical medicine
casey n pinto nurse practitioner pa
department of health std clinic and
infectious disease associates and
assistant professor public health
sciences penn state cancer institute
and david t pride associate professor of
pathology director of molecular
microbiology
associate director of microbiology
university of california san diego
patty casey and david you may now begin
your presentation
hi everyone and welcome to my section of
the presentation my name is casey pinto
and i'm here to talk to you about kind
of the real life
lived experiences or what providers on
the ground are seeing during covet and
up to now
so first i like to refresh us all on
what happened in
march of 2020 because
even though it was only two years ago it
seems like so much longer
but essentially what happened for our
state health centers
our std clinics that are staffed by dis
officers is that we saw a large majority
of them being redeployed to
not just fight coronavirus but really to
do contact tracing we saw our clinics
shut down
as we decided how to move forward most
places moved to telehealth
because of this these changes barbie's
group came out with these clinical
guidelines for sexually transmitted
infections um the four main takeaways
and while this you know obviously with
100 percent care or best practice these
aren't the best recommendations but
during covid these were the best
recommendations that would keep people
safe from coven
while also doing our best to treat stis
so we were deferring sti screening
visits so these are your patients who
just came in routinely to get screened
we were treating persons with known
exposure via telephone and telemed with
oral medications
um which we all know isn't the best for
syphilis and chlamydia
sorry syphilis and gonorrhea
but it was something we had to decide to
do at this point in time
to kind of prevent
exposure to covid we were triaging
patients with symptoms using telemed and
we were continuing to provide in-person
clinical care for select patients with
symptoms
so those that you really couldn't make a
diagnosis over the phone and although
these were the best practices many
clinics were not adhering to this
simply due to
physical constraints other issues going
on
um
and the inability to see patients in the
office
specifically this really impacted the
std field uh like the the std
state health centers
and this report from the national
coalition of std directors from may of
2020 really starts to outline that 83
percent of programs were deferring
services or field visits
62 percent couldn't maintain their hiv
and syphilis caseloads which i know and
i'm sure dr kissinger is going to talk
about syphilis
and and the results of that as as a
piece of the result of this
66 of clinics reported a decrease in
sexual health screening 60 of clinics
were
at reduced capacity 57
reported that they or other dis have
been redeployed to coven 19. so
easily over half of every std state
health center
that was in this poll
reported
a decrease in services and our std
services are already stretched to the
max
and this was a positive thing that we
actually have the ability to perform
field visits remotely and virtually but
only 32 of them had that
i'd love to see an update on where this
is but it's not present
so right now
the majority
41.79 had to reduce services by more
than 50 percent and and less than 20 did
not have to reduce any sexual health
testing
as of may 2020
now
has it reduced clinic capacity again
only 40 had no changes to std clinic
capacity while the other
60ish percent had something
to some extent of um clinic capacity
reduction
and i love pointing this out because we
talk about sti testing as one of the
mainstays of service and what you see
here is the number of tests done by
quest diagnostics since january of 2019
until june
well it's actually august of 2020. so
when you look across you see your normal
blips for
memorial day
july 4th labor day
um
thanksgiving
christmas new year
and then you see this huge tank once the
us did their coveted shutdown
and i think that's really important
because this isn't telling you
how many people are testing positive
this is telling you how many people are
getting tested and there's a huge 60
drop in the number of people that are
tested but the positivity rate per test
went up simply because we suspect that
symptomatic people were getting tested
at that point in time
and this is chlamydia and gonorrhea by
volume and of course those tests are
hand in hand right because they're the
urine nat so the majority of the time
you're going to see an equal number
and then if you look at the actual and
anticipated committee of positive
as of
june 21st we were still below
our expected chlamydia positivity rate
but if you look at gonorrhea
you see that that has skyrocketed and
we'll talk a little bit about why
perhaps the chlamydia rate hasn't come
up and i know that dr kissinger will
likely talk about that as well in her
talk
so i'll try not to beleaguer it
but
the national coalition of std directors
increased
sorry they redid the report in january
of 2021 and what they found
was that 90 of these std
health centers because remember all of
our dis officers the majority of dis
officers in the u.s are for std we do
have other diseases where they do
contact tracing but the majority are
working on std as some aspect of their
workload and 90 percent we're doing
coven 19 contact tracing
37
as of january 2021 we're redeployed 87
are leading staffing assisting or
supporting coven 19.
covet 19 redeployments were interfering
with their ability to provide disease
intervention including a 28 decrease in
chlamydia a 23 decrease in syphilis
services and an 18 decrease in gonorrhea
services
um while i think chlamydia and gonorrhea
are incredibly important and should be i
think when dr kissinger talks
you'll see why this 23 decrease in
syphilis services may have had a huge
impact on
current sti rates
i'm sorry i'm [ __ ] too much so for me
a little bit about me i am an infectious
disease nurse practitioner but i also
work in
the city of york sti clinic
uh in their sexual wellness clinic so
i'm there one day a week i see patients
there pre-pandemic we had a walk-in
from you know we say it's 10 to 2 30 but
really it's like nine to five so when
the patients stopped coming i stopped
seeing patients
we were really busy and we had about a
20 positivity rate so really high rate
before the pandemic pandemic hit we had
to shut down because we only had two dis
officers
and they both got redeployed to covet
and were essentially
not functioning in the role of std
we slowly started to reopen
and then covered searched again and we
had to shut down again
um
which was problematic because people had
started coming so now we're opening we
opened again we've been open for several
months but we decided not to do walk-in
yet
until we see what's really going to
happen with the pandemic so right now
i'm seeing scheduled appointments only
which impacts the number of patients i
see
because most people want to walk in they
don't want to schedule an appointment
and i'm seeing a lot of no-shows but the
patients i am seeing
i'm seeing a high rate of syphilis much
higher than i've ever expected i've done
more darkfield microscopy exams
than ever which i know is not the norm
but it's something i was trained on so
i'm lucky enough to have in the office
so i get to do those i've diagnosed
several syphilis cases just with
darkfield obviously we sent it out for
testing to confirm but i was able to
increase uh partner notification or
start partner notification earlier
which is the only reason why i do
darkfield um so syphilis is really
what i've been seeing a lot of our
positivity rate is much higher
than it was even before so we're at like
30 right now and that's because patients
are coming in who've been told that they
were positive by someone else
patients who are symptomatic
we're getting a much smaller number of
patients who
um
are just coming for routine screening
and i don't know if it's because they've
just decided not to come or if they're
seeking care elsewhere
now while i don't practice in the
emergency room or or an ob gyn
i've received more calls this year from
colleagues in the er or urgent care
asking how to treat patients
for diseases that
i've surprised that they're even
screening for so one of the cases we saw
was
a patient had a positive mycoplasma
genitalium and they
their provider who screen for had no
idea what to do so they sent them to the
er so i get a call from the er what do i
do
i feel like this doesn't need to be in
the air and i'm like no you're right it
doesn't um
so we treated for that
i'm seeing a much higher rate of calls
for
interpreting syphilis results
so patients are being screened they're
positive they're positive two months ago
the titer did not decrease at all and
they don't know what to do
um
so i'm seeing a lot of calls for
syphilis for that
overall i've received maybe one call a
week and i'm up to probably five to six
calls a week from urgent care alone
and then ob
you know i really never get i have never
received calls from ob groups ever
um
but i think the issue with this increase
of syphilis that we're seeing in our
practice is they're catching more
in ob so they're trying to figure out
next steps for a while there was a
bicillin shortage and we couldn't treat
them it was
a mess that i'm sure you guys are also
dealing with um
the other thing i'm seeing is resistant
trick
which we didn't know was resistant or
not
and you can't send for testing because
the cdc is currently not doing resistant
trick testing
so you know we had to work with some of
our colleagues to get these specimens
shipped out
to get them tested in a research lab to
see if it's resistant to trick um
so a lot of things coming up that i
haven't seen before which makes me
really concerned about what's going to
come up when we really get back
into testing completely and i'll talk
about that now because i think this is
really important to talk about as a lot
of these places transition to telehealth
they're sending patients to do
urine screenings
or get blood tests at labs
and they're not coming in so
you know a women's routine health visit
pre pandemic and this i picked women 21
to 29 because if you're going for
cervical cancer screening at 25 to 29
you should also be getting at least at
one point in time chlamydia and
gonorrhea screening and this is
asymptomatic and i know we pick up a lot
at these but what you saw was in 2019
you had this like nice stable trend but
in 2020
it went from boop
to no screening to and we still weren't
at baseline in september
so what likely will happen is all these
women
or
you know trans women or whoever
all these people
were getting screened and that got
pushed off um
and it unfortunately got pushed off for
who knows how long because we haven't
seen a follow-up to this but that also
means that the routine screening was
also pushed off
and now because of what i do
i really needed to talk on rural urban
disparities because i think it's really
important
there is literally nothing in the
literature right now about sti rates
during covid um in rural versus urban
population so if anyone's out there
that's a researcher that now's the time
to do it i know from talking to
colleagues in alaska and other states
that you know using things like i want
the kit has really improved access for
some patients but overall the biggest
barrier for rural health is access to
care
so there are all these other disparities
but the biggest barrier is access to
care
so negative thing is according to this
report the impact of covet 19 financial
status of many rural hospitals are paris
lee on the precipice of closing so we
may be losing one of our biggest access
points to care but on the other hand
we're seeing a rapid scale up of
telehealth during copen 19
with subsequent implications and this is
just some specialty care but i think
with the
advent and acceptance of this that we
may be seeing more so
that's my end um
and i'm gonna
turn it over to dr kissinger
and now we'll hear from
dr patty kissinger
thanks so much dr pinto
my name is dr patty kissinger i'm here
to talk
to you about the effects of copin 19
pandemic on sexually transmitted
infection care where do we go from here
so dr pinto did a great description of
all the challenges that she as a
clinician has seen in the field
uh with respect to
uh
restrictions that were imposed because
of coven 19. and i want to go into a
little bit of what we can do and what
lessons we've learned
so as she mentioned there's there was a
dramatic reduction in sti screening and
that was for many reasons
the restrictions of the shutdowns of the
clinics the clinics were being diverted
and we would be re required to take care
of many more covid patients
uh in addition to that there was issues
with sourcing of
materials and equipment
urine cups were hard to come by dacron
suaves are hard to come by so uh the
there was a confluence of many different
things that uh resulted in many less
people getting screened for sexually
transmitted infections
so we do did see despite the fact that
so few people or fewer people were being
screened we did see a rebound of many
much more syphilis that was going on and
you can see here from this graph uh in
2020 uh that the rates were as high as
early 90s when we were seeing one of the
highest rates of syphilis uh
historically and so all of the great
interventions that had been done prior
to the covet pandemic
were kind of refuted by this uh or
negated by uh this pandemic and so uh
you will see probably
the sti's that are traditionally are
more symptomatic you'll probably see
higher rates of those the ones that are
tend to be less symptomatic such as
chlamydia you're going to see less rates
because less
fewer people have been
tested
and as as dr pinto mentioned the use of
televisions which was actually we were
starting uh you know health uh
care was starting to use televisions to
access
populations that had had difficulty in
accessing normal care they would use
televisions such as rural communities
and other communities that
such as underrepresented communities
that did not necessarily go into clinics
so the use of televisions
was amplified
greatly during covid and i think it's
here to stay i think that
patients like it
providers like it for the most part um
but there are some downsides to it is
that television you can't always do a
physical exam so you might miss out on
some things but at least it does provide
more access to people so i think
refining televisions is going to be
helpful
other possible solutions are moving
outside of the clinic clinic has always
been problematic for underserved
populations there's mistrust there's
fear there's lack of insurance there's
stigma there's myriad reasons why people
won't want to go to a clinic so the
possibility of screening people for
sexually transmitted infections uh
outside of the clinic will be very
helpful and we saw that this in hiv it
was very successful you know there was
lots of it was launched with much
trepidation people were concerned that
people may not access care they were
concerned that it wouldn't get reported
so it wouldn't be included in
surveillance and these are all issues
that still need to be worked out but it
does provide an opportunity so home
testing and point of care testing point
of care testing is a great because it
can really reduce the time that a person
must wait to get the results and so that
can
can help be very helpful so um
point of care test versus laboratory
tests so laboratory tests usually you
have to send it out it may take a couple
of days if it's a point of care test you
usually can get in a much reduced time
frame which will have lots of advantages
clinic versus home test clinic is uh
clinic best
testing is uh
optimal because you can also engage with
a
physical examination
and you can
actually see the person
so home testing is not as great for that
but it's really great for access to care
so some people that may not wouldn't
traditionally go to clinic
also clio wave versus non-clue wave if
some of these tests uh require
instrumentation some of them require to
be certified for clia um and some of
them uh so there are some issues with
some of these
there's a
plethora of
point of care testing that is out there
and many of them are they some of them
take 10 minutes some of them takes 90
minutes some of them require specific
instrumentation some of them are on
their own
and so there are all sorts of different
varieties of this and we're going to see
more and more point of care tests uh uh
being introduced for all of the sexually
transmitted infections so the advantage
of these point of care tests is they're
very uh
predictive they're very accurate
sensitive and specific they allow for a
quicker diagnosis they retur reduce the
participant burden so they don't have to
go in uh maybe wait for a very long time
at the clinic or maybe come back for a
visit if they are found to be positive
and they've already left the clinic so
that can reduce that it can also help
with uh better
antibiotic stewardship so you will not
necessarily
be
treated in a
syndromic manner rather you can use a
real test to do that and so that would
have would be a very important uh
initiative the disadvantages they're
they're quite expensive in fact for the
most part they are more expensive than
laboratory based not all as i mentioned
before clia waived and so that means
that there may be some other regulations
that they have to be stored certain ways
they have to be um they can't be they
can't travel out into the field some of
them can and some of them cannot uh you
can't test for all sexually transmitted
infections some of them have a lot of
panels on them and some of them don't
they may miss other stis if no physical
examination is is done
and also many of the point of care tests
are not reported so unless there's
something like a bluetooth device or
some other mechanism
that they may not be reported and so
that would not figure into surveillance
we didn't see that so much as an issue
with hiv testing but if it becomes more
of our mainstay for sti testing it could
so that needs to be worked out and then
there can be omissions in reporting and
billing and so for example sometimes
people don't get reimbursed for their
home test and that can be very costly so
a person if they went to the clinic they
just pay a copay but now they're paying
for the full test and that could be very
expensive unless uh insurance would
cover it so this is what the gold
standard for point of care test in my
mind would look like it would be rapid
um it would be definitely point of care
it could be done at the home or in the
clinic or anywhere out in the field
and also the results are reported to the
local jurisdictions that require that
reporting such as
local offices of public health and
eventually the cdc so if we can move
towards this this would be great
so moving outside of the clinic um one
of the first initiatives ever done was i
want the kit this is done in baltic it
started in baltimore now it's uh serves
all of maryland and they just moved to
alaska so there's some areas where you
can just simply sign up you get a kit
they send it to you if you're positive
they give you the results you can bring
that into your provider and get cared
for so this has been very effective and
um dr
charlotte gatos and her group have
really published a lot on this and it's
really quite um it was quite uh
avant-garde for the time um and so i
mentioned you do have to have internet
access so there are some people that may
not have that you do also have to have
the will or the want you have to desire
to be tested and some people don't have
that they don't know that they have to
be tested there is another initiative
called get yourself tested which is
what was initiated by the centers for
disease control and prevention i believe
it was in in partnership with mtv and
some other groups where they had really
great uh advertisement for it
and um it was promoted greatly on uh std
week which is in april and they got a
lot of people tested they you know
disseminated to high schools and
colleges and other areas
so i'm going to talk a little bit more
about our which is in non-traditional
venues
we had
uh we have just for the last five years
been embarking upon the check it program
check it as a community community-based
screening the goal of check it was to uh
as you know cdc does not recommend
screening women men for chlamydia or
gonorrhea they do recommend screening
young sexually active women under the
age of 25
and so that they don't have these
recommendations for men so we wanted to
determine
if
men
screening men could have any impact on
women so we
engaged we enlisted about 50 partners
many of them were from recreational
facilities historically black colleges
and universities training facilities
we did barber shops
and
historically black owned communities and
we were focusing on african-american
young men because they're nine times
more likely to have chlamydia than their
white counterparts we also focused in on
new orleans because it was a
predominantly black
city so um and i happened to live there
so that helped but anyway um it is uh
this is uh we engaged on this in this um
and so to be enrolled in study had to be
15 to 26 years of age we started 24 and
then we found out the
guys were having sex with younger women
so we um elongated at the age to 26 they
had to be black or african american they
had to have a penis and they had to live
or spend most of their time in or in in
new orleans proper and they had to have
had sex with a woman at least once so we
were focusing on men who have sex with
women they could have had sex with men
too about seven percent of them did but
because we know a lot about home testing
for gay men or gay bisexual men but what
we don't know is for the men who have
sex with women so that's why we decided
to focus in on and those are the men
that are giving the infection to the
women
so they got free testing they also got
incentivized testing you got 25 for
being in the study um they could use
that towards money for a visa card or
they could get their hair cut for free
with that 25 whatever they wanted
um we also if they were positive we gave
them medication um we gave medication
for themselves and any sex partner that
they um gave us information on we gave
them the medication to bring to that sex
partner we also retested them in three
months if they were positive and we
referred them uh anytime that they were
positive we also referred them to go get
a full battery of sexually trans uh
uh an sti examination because we figured
once you have one sti you're probably
more likely to get have other stis
so it was easy they just gave urine
specimen they engaged on a little survey
on their phone if they were positive
they could go to one of the pharmacies
mostly there were walgreens but we did
have one local pharmacy
and uh then they would get the medicine
for themselves and their partners and um
and so it was a simple
but quite bundled intervention and it
really kind of hit on expedited partner
treatment and screening and all that so
i think that
that
now i want to say tell you about did it
work or not
so what we found is yes indeed we were
able to screen over 2600 men
um and the
infection rate for chlamydia was about
11 percent and for gonorrhea was just
shy of two percent uh we uh published
that in std
um we also looked to see did it affect
any change in the rate in women and as
you can see the dotted line is for our
control sites that didn't have check it
and the
uh
non-dashed liner the solid line is for
the check it site and you can see it was
statistically significantly lower the
rates in women
for those who were
women who were living in the check it
area you can see our mathematical
modeling on the bottom right hand side
when we started the intervention you
could see after about
a year or so possibly two years you
started to see a reduction in the rates
not just in men because we were
screening them but also in women and so
this is mathematical modeling that we
did and we found that it did have an
effect on women so we see that through
the medicaid data up up on the top and
then through the mathematical modeling
we also did a cost effectiveness study
and found that it was cost effective um
that it uh the
cost of the intervention was minimal
compared to the qualities that um were
gained
so in summary sti care is likely to
change forever it was moving that way
anyway but this really propelled it into
a faster mode
we're going to see more and more home
testing more and more point of care
testing is going to be available and in
order to
survive structural shocks so i live in a
hurricane
vulnerable area some people live in
fire
area vulnerable areas coveted hit
everybody um so there are going to
probably unfortunately be more
structural shocks
with climate change and everything and
so this could serve as a way to help us
serve our clientele um in in the face of
these structural shocks and also it's a
great way to reduce health disparities
stis are notorious for health
disparities just about every single one
of them uh cause it
has demonstrates uh that
usually persons of color are more likely
to get the sti so this could be another
way of reducing those health disparities
and so more and more non-clinic-based
options are needed and it is my hope
that check it could serve as one of
those models
for it thank you very much for your
attention and
thank you patty and now we'll hear from
david pride
hello
thank you so much for attending today
i am dr pride i'm the director of the
microbiology laboratory at uc san diego
health
and i and my colleagues today are going
to talk to you guys a little bit about
sexually transmitted infections uh
during times of covenant
specifically i'm going to talk to you
guys about
testing challenges that we encountered
during the times of covet and how that
may very well have contributed to some
of the
more global
epidemiological trends that we're
observing uh in sexually transmitted
infections
so i've got a few goals for this webinar
the first is to really provide an
overview of some of the things that
happen with sexually transmitted
infection testing particularly during
the early stages of the coven 19
pandemic
we want to identify some of the trends
that
really had an impact upon testing
particularly things like consumables and
the availability of staffing
during the pandemic
we want to discuss what the lack of
testing potentially means particularly
for patients
as well as trends and sexually
transmitted infections and to end
talking a little bit about some
potentially long-lasting trends uh that
we've observed with things like for
example home testing for sexually
transmitted uh infections
so
a little bit about the role of the
clinical lab in sexually transmitted uh
infection testing
it's probably a bit overlooked um
and it while in general it might not
always be overlooked particularly during
the times of covid i i think
it got overlooked quite a bit and part
of that
really has to do with the fact that all
of our energy
really went to developing testing for
covet 19 so that we could respond to the
global pandemic one of the things that
was really in the background the entire
time
is whether or not we can perform all of
the other testing that a clinical
microbiology laboratory would normally
perform
in the midst of the covet 19 pandemic so
for example my individual laboratory
performs over a hundred different tests
and while we put almost all of our
energy into developing single tests just
for colvin
one of the big question marks was can we
continue to perform those other hundred
tests really in the face of what's going
on
right now and that was a really big
problem not just for our laboratory but
for really laboratories uh across the
world
the demand uh for some of these sexually
transmitted infections um uh did go down
as which we will talk about uh but it
decreased really for a myriad of reasons
um one is that we have a lot less people
who were seeing their physicians at the
time and a large part of that was just
fear uh perhaps on both the part of the
physician as well as that the
individuals uh for contracting uh
coveted um
the uh unfortunate circumstances usually
that led people to uh
seek out sexually transmitted infection
testing all of those things really
remain um it's just that we were doing a
lot less testing uh during that period
of time so laboratories like ours really
had to figure out well how do we
prioritize all of this over testing uh
all of this other type of testing where
the real priority right now is how do we
provide culvert testing to respond to
the pandemic so a laboratory like ours
performs a lot of different uh tests for
sexy transmitted infections and while
this is not a comprehensive list these
are some of the things that we would
normally test for so for example we test
for chlamydia trachomatis
nyseria gonorrhea we test for syphilis
we test for hiv we test for hepatitis b
hepatitis c we test for human
papillomavirus we also test for herpes
simplex viruses type 1 and type 2.
what we observed during the pandemic
were
really some significant decreases in the
amount of testing that we were
performing and the the one thing i
wanted you to keep in mind is that we
perform all the tests that are sent to
us um so if there's less tests it's not
because we uh we wanted to perform less
tests it's because less tests were sent
to us largely because less physicians
were ordering tests probably because
less people were coming to them uh to uh
seek uh clinical care so our uh testing
volumes uh decreased uh uh in the period
of 2020. remember the pandemic uh
started late 2019 uh started to become
really apparent probably around march of
2020
and uh
we've been in this pandemic really since
then
so most of the decreases in testing that
we observe uh are fairly specific to the
year uh 2020 and as you can see here we
performed less tests for gonorrhea and
chlamydia less tests for hiv less tests
for hepatitis b
less tests for syphilis
less tests for human papilloma virus and
we also
believe we perform less tests for herpes
simply expires and while 2020 was an
increase if you look at 2021 compared to
2019 we were performing about double the
number of tests uh uh in that uh
between that time period and we believe
that
to a large extent uh that in the year
2020 while we did see a slight increase
in testing um that uh increase in
testing is not nearly uh the increase
that we would have observed had there
not been a pandemic so just overall in
our laboratory what we're still
observing are our increases in tests
over time now um anywhere between 20 to
30 percent for most of these uh
tests but they were significantly
decreased particularly right around
march
of 2020
again there are multitude of factors
that are involved in uh impacting this
testing the hesitancy for
person visits uh we sort of touched upon
but a lot of it really has to do with um
growing pains from developing the idea
of virtual visits many institutions
didn't have you know uh basically uh an
internet type of visit that you could
have uh with your patients
and
many institutions like our own started
those sorts of visits unfortunately one
of the things you can uh
figure out from that is that you kind of
need an internet connection to have a
virtual visit uh so uh a large number of
patients in essence were kind of shut
out uh from clinical care uh because of
the uh move to our virtual visits
the availability of testing
really wasn't something that was widely
publicized it wasn't widely publicized
because
it was so widely publicized that there
were deficits or deficiencies and
coveted testing that most people weren't
really thinking that much about well
what's going on with sexually
transmitted infection testing
and one of the uh things that really was
occurring as as you can imagine is that
uh as manufacturers were trying to ramp
up
uh their uh consumables uh so that they
could supply laboratories like ours with
kova testing because for example they
didn't have a bunch of additional
factories so that they could just bring
more and more and more consumables
to the market
what tended to happen was that they
would shift
their current manufacturing from one
thing to something else
and one of the things that uh they
shifted from were sexually transmitted
infection consumables um so we had a
significant deficit in the number of uh
sexually transmitted uh infection uh
consumables than we would normally have
throughout
that time
you can see over time
particularly again right around march of
2020
that uh you know doctor visits were
significantly
uh impacted compared for example uh to
the same time uh in 2019 and those uh
dot in person doctor visits really still
have not gone back uh to a hundred
percent uh and and that's just largely
because the virus continues to be around
but also because institutions uh really
have decided that virtual visits uh are
probably a a thing to use in the future
uh as well so that
if you look for example at what's going
on in the uk because they track their uh
uh their patient visits really really
closely um you can see that in the year
2020 they started having either
telephone or these sort of not in person
virtual
visits
and
they those continue throughout 2020 at
our institution they're continuing all
the way to 2022 and we view them really
as a staple of our clinical care uh in
the uh future as well
one of the other things that we saw
particularly right around 2020 was an
impact on people getting vaccinated for
example human papilloma virus is a
disease of which there is a vaccination
available for some wart causing viruses
as well as some
cancer-associated viruses and we saw
those uh really plummet uh
in 2020 again a casualty of having a
pandemic with a lot less in-person uh
doctor visits so at some point we might
uh very well
see a a reciprocal sort of increase in
hpv infections as a result of the fact
there are less
hpv vaccinations taking place during
that time period of course we saw a lot
less
tests for
bacterial
sexually transmitted infections like
chlamydia like gonorrhea and like
syphilis and one of the things that
we've observed is in in essence a
rebound so while we saw a significant
decrease uh again
the decrease uh does not necessarily
mean that people didn't need to be
tested
in other words uh the one and one of the
toughest things about
the decrease is that if disease is still
there
then people are probably still spreading
the disease so we have seen significant
increases uh in sexually transmitted
infections now that we are uh back to
testing about a hundred percent of what
we were uh before in fact
again in my institution we're testing
about 120
of what we were before and we're seeing
really high rates
of disease
in california where i am uh we uh noted
uh particularly during that year 2020 uh
we we saw less
tests for chlamydia less testosterone
gonorrhea about 30 percent less tests
for hiv
about 25 less tests for syphilis as well
again these diseases did not go away
it's just the testing for them uh
significantly was impacted by the
pandemic so uh
unfortunately we could see reciprocal
increases
in those
diseases largely because they were still
there they just were not being diagnosed
at the time
so lots of people lots of parts of the
country were impacted by the reduced
testing that we saw uh in the pandemic
not every region was affected uh equally
as you guys uh can kinda see by this
sort of snapshot um
looking at uh some testing volumes where
the northeast was a little different
from the west was a little different uh
from the southeast um but the take home
message really is everyone was impact
whether impacted whether it was equally
or not
entire institutions were impacted there
were clear winners and unfortunately
clear losers uh in the uh quest really
to garner testing consumables so that
you could test your patient populations
uh during the pandemic
larger facilities tended to do better
than smaller facilities uh for example
as you guys will hear a bit more about
uh in this hour uh in particular uh
minorities underserved communities uh
rural communities uh were impacted uh
really significantly uh by the uh the
lack of testing uh that uh that was
available
one of the big things that led to some
of the lack of testing
is were consumable shortages as we
mentioned companies had to shift their
manufacturing and we just looked at a
survey
basically of microbiology laboratories
and the one thing that probably really
jumps out is the
significant
deficit that most laboratories had
and
their ability to test for sexually
transmitted infections
i really think it was for our
institution it was just lucky that we
didn't receive the normal number of
tests that we would because we would not
have been able to perform all of those
tests because we simply didn't have the
consumables uh to do so and all around
the country it's the same story most
labs didn't have the consumables uh to
be able to test all of those patients
and uh of course that it has a sort of
wide-ranging
uh uh reach here um that could have a
number of different impact uh on patient
populations because certainly there were
institutions where they just couldn't uh
test people who showed up to be tested
at our institution we could but that as
i mentioned earlier that's probably just
luck
the other thing that really impacted uh
is staffing shortages we had significant
staffing shortages all around the
country and one uh one of the uh
responses the government had was to
allow laboratories like ours to use
unlicensed personnel to perform uh some
of the testing and that was absolutely
necessary to be able to make it through
at least the earlier uh parts of this
pandemic part of that is because we have
cls's clinical laboratory scientists
who are superbly trained to perform
these tests but they are
a bit of an aging group that uh um and
we're seeing significant declines as uh
the group is retiring uh unfortunately
we're not seeing a bunch of graduates
who are replacing them um so this sort
of work work shortage that was in a lot
of ways accelerated by the pandemic is
something that's going to continue
really into the future other things that
impact uh
laboratories of course the laboratories
made a lot of investments in equipment
um and that will affect some of their
testing moving forward because a lot of
institutions are going to try to use
that equipment so that they can recoup
their large investments
clia wave tests um are kind of a thing
of the present but certainly more of a
thing of the future and what that means
basically is that some of these
relatively sophisticated tests will be
able to be run
right in your doctor's office for
example
and not require that your doctor send
the test to a laboratory like ours to be
tested
imagine your patients being able to come
to your office
get a test right there in your office
and be provided with the result before
they go home so that is a trend
that is kind of here now but certainly a
wave of the future another wave of the
future is the idea of at home testing
and at home testing we sort of seen
start
to expand a large part of the expansion
which probably due to the pandemic and
there are a lot of places um
that are starting to offer this and
they're offering it even without an
individual doctor's visit where for an
individual can swab themselves or
provide urine in a cup and be tested for
a myriad of different sexually
transmitted diseases so these are things
that are all sort of coming in our
armamentarium
to help sort of battle the crisis that
is the increase in sexually transmitted
infections so with that uh broad
overview of some of the challenges that
we've had uh to sexually transmitted
infections during times of this pandemic
i will turn it over to my colleagues who
will talk a bit more about some of these
sexually transmitted infections and
their challenges thank you
thank you again casey patty and david
for your time today and your important
research
we'll now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started
our first question is for patty do you
think that covid19 pandemic has
increased or decreased sti rates
thanks for that question um that is a
complicated question and uh it's
partially because it's unknowable with
our our surveillance system right now is
imperfect we are we base all of our
surveillance on case rates so case rates
come from people who are tested and are
found to be positive and the denominator
is the census and this is generally done
throughout the world so um what happens
with that is we don't really know so if
less people get tested you have less uh
in the numerator and so you can't really
know um so i think that um
uh
we're going to probably
see a big surge um because many people
who are asymptomatic didn't get tested
even some of those who were symptomatic
couldn't get in to get tested so we will
see a surge
and i don't know how long it will take
for that to surge to quell but um i
don't know if my other colleagues have
anything else to say about that
our next question
how long do you think it will take for
sti rates to
recover from the pandemic
so i can take this one and kind of just
segue off the last question that patty
had um
we don't know right and we just saw the
newest cdc guidelines come or the newest
cdc to statistics good lord it's a day
come out that shows that chlamydia is
has actually decreased from the previous
year and this all
while all the other stis have increased
um
and what all we can say is exactly what
patty said you know we don't actually
have a denominator here we don't know
how many people are getting tested and
we know that chlamydia is often found
in patients who are going in for
asymptomatic screening and we know that
that's decreased so i do not think our
rates have recovered yet i think we're
going to see a spike with chlamydia over
the next year and i wouldn't be
surprised if gonorrhea and syphilis keep
rising but these are all theories
and only time will tell what actually
does happen
next question how do you think
televisions will affect sti care
i can also take this one if no one else
wants to
um i think that tele visits are
fantastic i think they are going to
drastically increase access especially
to populations who don't have that
access like your rural populations or
your lgbt
health populations
but
i also think that tele visits are going
to hinder care so patients who just use
these for convenience who do have access
to clinics may not be getting the right
antibiotics that they need because we
can't prescribe you an injection
over the phone
you actually have to come into a clinic
site to get that
and it's also going to impact
surveillance data and how much we're
actually getting reported from all of
these tests
all right thank you
this next question is for david
is sdi testing now readily available as
it was pre pandemic
yeah uh well uh so sti testing has been
able to increase
most of the companies that are producing
the consumables for sdi tests really
have ramped up significantly so at an
institution like ours and academic
institutions they are readily and freely
available the way that they used to be
um so i think on the whole uh we're
probably back to where we need to be
that doesn't mean that every single
institution across the country has the
access that they need right now
but certainly um the number of tests
that we have available to us now are
greater than they were pre pre-penned in
it
can i just add something to that um
davey that that's uh really important
what you pointed out another thing to
say is that our sti testing even before
covid was not very good
first of all if you're a young person
who thinks you might have an sti
and you're beholden to your parents for
insurance and to bring you to a clinic
and you don't want to tell your parents
you're not going to go get tested it was
very imperfect and also
primary care doctors should be testing
anybody who's sexually active
particularly well women right now but
hopefully they'll move towards men as
well they should be testing them and
that doesn't always happen and so i
think that even though even if we
rebound back to where we were
pre-covered it wasn't adequate
right thank you
next question
in india due to absence of any formal
adolescent adult sex education hygiene
safe sex and sti prevention education
and on the other hand with mo with
almost universal access to internet porn
sti situation is very dire
governments and education boards are
apathetic or embarrassed what are the
panel's remedial suggestions
i can take that uh i can start it off
and i'm sure everybody here the other
panelists have uh comments but i'll just
say because i live in the delta south of
uh the united states it's very
conservative here and i would say well
it's maybe not quite as conservative as
india but it's very conservative and so
we have the same uh issues sex education
is sporadic it's uh disjointed and it's
definitely not comprehensive in many
parts of the united states so my
suggestions are just keep fighting the
good fight keep bringing it to the fore
keep letting people know about it let
your legislators know about it let you
know do everything you can to raise
awareness because the public needs to be
aware of this
and and they don't want to be because
it's it's a kind of a topic people don't
want to talk about and i'm sure others
have things to say but
yeah i've actually done some work in
india not in sti specifically but i
think that the nice thing in india is
that pharmacies are open like you can
come up and just ask for a prescription
so these point-of-care tests that we're
really pushing for since covet hit well
before covet but now that it hit they're
really coming to the market i think
that's going to be your key
and putting out education online to the
people who are accessing the porn sites
through those porn sites through other
avenues so that they can
so they know and they can get themselves
tested and then subsequently can get
themselves the treatment which is not as
easy to do in the u.s
you kind of have to circumvent the
government a little bit in india to get
this done though because they're never
going to push it through
um this next question is for patty
really excellent and exciting work in
the check it program what else do you
think is needed in order to shift the
cdc guidelines to more broadly encompass
all sexually active people
as opposed to the current focus on msm
and young women
thank you for that great question thank
you for the compliment yes we really
have enjoyed working in the check it
program i think the i i feel very sorry
for cdc right now they're they're
they're being pulled in so many
different directions and with very few
resources we have a very fragile sti
infrastructure here in the united states
and i think you could say that of many
places um and i think that without the
um
uh
without more resources and funding it
may be difficult for them so what
they've done is you focus in on the
persons who have the highest prevalence
which of course is men who have sex with
men and young women but but men as you
could see in our check it program they
were all african-american and they all
lived in this deep south but they had
really high rates so i think we need to
figure out the pockets of where the
folks are that have high rates and you
have to turn over stones because we like
i don't know that people even studied uh
young black men before and so i think
that uh when young black heterosexual or
men who have sex with women so i think
just um uh
giving getting more resources to cdc and
making sure and and will they change the
guidelines i was on the consultation in
2007 and they said the reason that they
didn't do it is because they didn't have
data and they didn't know about
feasibility well now with check we
provided them with the data and we've
provided them with the feasibility and i
didn't really get that many i'm not
getting that much interest in it so i
need more and more people to be
interested in this maybe people
reproduce our study in other areas i'm
happy to help if anybody wants to but i
think that uh we really there is room we
do need to take care of our young people
who don't who aren't covered in these
areas thanks
all right thank you next question
is it better to multiplex these tests
so uh you know um
it it is good to multiplex some tests uh
i have to admit you know if you were to
ask 10 different physicians uh the
answer to this question you may very
well get 10 different answers
unfortunately the one thing i can say
that we do do is that we monitor
physician behavior when it comes to say
a singleplex test versus a multiplex
test
because we constantly do get physicians
who will tell you they only want a
singleplex test i
quite frankly am one of them sometimes
who's saying that the exact same thing
but what we find is that if you can
offer a multiplex test at a reasonable
cost um and get results to physicians
quickly
usually that's going to be the one they
choose regardless of
quite frankly whether they tell you
that's the one they want or not
all right thank you it looks like we
have time for one more question
do you feel the development of
naat and point of care will increase the
diversity in testing market or funnel it
um
well you know i think uh yeah most
people really do feel like
adding uh point of care testing is
really important because it uh just
increases the number of different
populations in the diversity of the
populations that are capable
in essence of being tested so
there really is a critical need to
develop high quality point of care
testing um
to to really uh
to be able to meet the needs of our
patient populations ideally they would
be nucleic acid amplification test as uh
you're sort of pointing out uh
particularly right now the standard of
care for gonorrhea and chlamydia is
nucleic acid amplification tests so uh
if there can be
care tests that do a really good job and
are cost effective at doing that then
absolutely it's going to meet
really a critical need for the
population
can i just add one thing though as i
mentioned before
you can't it's great to have this
diversity of tests and i applaud it and
i hope we continue to produce more and
more but you have to also stimulate the
interest in this for example if i'm a
young person that has chlamydia i'm
asymptomatic
what's go what's prompting me to go get
tested so if it's if it were relying on
home tests you the assumption is that
the populace understands that they need
to be tested so it can't be done in an
isolation we really need to have in
tandem with
uh
education programs and awareness raising
awareness in the population
all right
well thank you again casey patty and
david for your time today and your
important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor roach diagnostics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you